last Drive in regulation knowing you
have to go 98 yards what's the message
to the team in the Huddle as you know
which is with just two minutes left as
you guys are going inside the game well
we're doing in practice all the time so
there's not really a shotgun or a
surprise to it it's just like okay we
like those high pressure moments like
that's that's what we live in and that's
I wish the whole game was just straight
that honestly that's when I say we Excel
but really like in my own mind I was
thinking Brady mode like he does it all
the time I got to be able to do it just
talking to him just you know and really
just representing him in that way
hey shador mcmiller Fox 31 you talk
about Tom Brady and all the work that
you put on with him and also coaches
talked about you this isn't the first
time you've had a moment like this it's
just a bigger stage that now people can
see it what have you learned from Brady
and where does this rank in terms of
moments that you've had in these kind of
pressurized moments
well also it's a lot of pressurized
moments but I remember the biggest
moment I remember was uh two moments
when my dad was
um he was going through the thing going
through the thing with his foot our
freshman year we do a game-winner
touchdown versus Southern not Southern
and um
the swag Champion not a swag
Championship the uh celebration Bowl
last year so it's just like I already I
already knew what what was required I
already been there before so it's like
I'm not I'm not going to be able to live
on myself honestly like on a loss like
that like I don't know I wouldn't be
able to sleep
so I just didn't want to go through that